[Music]
we still have two movies left from the
fast and furious franchise after the
ninth part was finally released
following several postponements there is
now news about fast and furious 10. as
universal has announced the 10th part
will be released on april 7 2023 in the
united states lead actor vin diesel did
not miss the opportunity to hint at the
story of the grand finale when asked why
two more films were being released the
54 year old claimed that universal did
not believe it was able to tell the
story in just one single film in
addition to vin diesel it is highly
likely that michelle rodriguez jodena
bruce de terry's gibson and swan kang
will be back in the cast as we already
reported a few weeks back dwayne johnson
will not be returning for the last two
parts which might be due to vin diesel
in particular what are your thoughts on
the fast and furious series and do you
really feel that two more movies are
necessary to conclude the film series
for good drop a comment down below and
let us know
frank herbert's dune book series has
enjoyed great popularity since the 1960s
the science fiction story has so far
been adapted for the screening david
lynch's dune from 1984 and in the two
mini-series frank herbert's dune and
children of dune in the early 2000s now
the long-awaited remake by blade runner
2049 director dennis villeneuve is
scheduled for release this year speaking
to games radar the 53 year old affirmed
at least to some extent the plans for a
sequel both warner brothers and
legendary pictures are supporting dune
completely which is why only very poor
box office numbers could get in the way
of the sequel the left already knows
what such a sequel could look like it
would not be called doom 2 but rather
dune part 2 and would follow the
original almost seamlessly he also
already knows who he would put at the
focus of the plot after timothy chalamet
plays the leading role in dune part 1
his co-star zendaya is to take over in
the second part as we'll never reveal in
an interview with the italian magazine
elviner di republica it would then be in
line with the book series where the
character chani only comes into greater
focus in the second half of the first
book in any case we are excited about
dennis velnev's remake which will be
released on october 22nd 2021
this summer disney hit the bold side
with free guy in terms of content the
film ranges somewhere in between the
truman show the matrix and an open world
video game this hybrid was well received
by critics movie audiences as well as
the typically critical gamer community
thus in this day and age it's not
surprising that they want to directly
follow up with the sequel main actor
ryan reynolds whose performance is
largely responsible for the movie
success appears to have nothing but
scorn for this idea however the 44 year
old tweets that disney has marked that
free guy as an iphone for three years in
other words as a completely original
story and not a spin-off of an already
well-known franchise only to now want to
turn it into a film series no official
announcement has yet been made about the
desire for sequel though in light of
reynolds tweet and the extremely
lucrative opening weekend it seems more
than plausible simply put using the
words of the deadpool star woohoo
[Music]
it has been known for some time that sam
wilson alias falcon will become the new
captain america after the end of the
disney plus series the falcon and the
winter soldier so far however anthony
mackie had not been officially committed
for captain america for which did raise
some questions now the wait is
officially over since according to use
magazine deadline mackie has finally
signed the contract appropriately enough
the two of the falcon and the winter
soldier writers malcolm spelman and
dalon mussen are panning the script so
there's a lot to suggest that captain
america four will tie in more or less
directly with the disney plus series
with the signing of mackie one
persistent rumor has been dispelled as
some fans were expecting a surprise
return of steve rogers as cap until
recently we are definitely looking
forward to the new captain america sadly
there is currently no release date for
the movie
the first fantasy novel in the wheel of
time series was published in 1990. in
the meantime a lot has happened with the
franchise because robert jordan's novel
is to become nothing less than amazon's
own game of thrones it's quite an
ambitious project and one that has been
finished shooting in eastern europe over
the past two years some new images
published exclusively by entertainment
weekly give us a first look at the
fantasy series among the other details
we can see the two main characters
equine oliver and randall thor the town
of shadologoth at night as well as the
mage logan content-wise this series
revolves around a team of young men and
women who embark on a long journey
moraine one of their members firmly
believes that one of the group could be
the reincarnation of a powerful
individual capable of either saving or
destroying humanity it certainly sounds
like an exciting story amazon's the
wheel of time will presumably be
released on the streaming service
sometime this year
the lord of the rings film series owes
its success not only to an exciting
story on brilliant actors but also and
above all to new zealand the island
state in the southern pacific ocean
served as the main location for the
impressive movie scenery of the lord of
the rings and the hobbit trilogies it
was therefore only natural that amazon
opted to shoot its ambitious mode of the
ring series there as well now just a few
days ago it was announced that the
project would be relocated to the united
kingdom in the future although the first
season will still be produced in new
zealand the project will be relocated to
europe for all further episodes the new
zealand government is not quite as
thrilled about this as it has generously
granted funding to the major project and
recently even approved the 5 subsidy on
the other hand great britain's culture
secretary oliver dalton is of course
delighted as he can now take credit for
the thousands of jobs that such a large
project brings along to his own country
the first season is scheduled to be
released on amazon prime on september
2nd 2022 so what do you guys think of
amazon's decision what local change of
scenery do the franchise any good or do
you think new zealand's rich landscape
cannot be replicated in the uk feel free
to let us know your opinion in the
comments
after the first three hotel transylvania
movies grossed a total of more than 1.3
billion us dollars at the global box
office fans are now eagerly awaiting the
release of hotel transylvania
transformania it has now been announced
that the fourth and final installment
will not be released in movie theaters
as planned instead it will be available
exclusively on amazon prime video as
variety reports the deal is worth 100
million us dollars and is intended to
prevent a potentially underwhelming
theatrical release further it is said
that they do not want to bring the
family movie to cinemas for fear that
the circulating delta variant and the
lack of vaccination for children under
12 years old might not bring the most
important target audience to the big
screen regardless the rights for the
later home theater television and the
chinese market remain with sony anyhow
the scary comedy will appear on amazon
prime on october 1st 2021 further news
from sony concerns the upcoming venom
leatherby carnage the much anticipated
blockbuster will be released in theaters
yet unfortunately the film's release has
once again been delayed luckily it's a
matter of only a few weeks but fans will
nonetheless have to say farewell to the
september release the action around
venom and is nasty adversary carnage
will then be released in use movie
theaters on october 15th 2021 as things
stand
[Music]
you